a movie has just come out called the
imitation game starring Benedict
Cumberbatch as Alan Turing and Keira
Knightley as one of the team that work
with cheering her name was Joan Clarke 5
minutes and 34 seconds you said to do it
in under six and I'm sure many of you
know Alan Turing worked at the
government code and cypher center at
Bletchley Park throughout the war right
from when it broke out in 1939 right
through until the end of war 1945 Alan
Turing was at Princeton doing research
with another very famous mathematical
logician called Alonzo Church he
returned from Princeton in 1938 but even
in that year from 3839 is very clear
that he was contacted by G C and C s
even though he wasn't employed by them
and became a sort of consultant became
acquainted with all of the difficulties
that were gonna hit the Allies when war
broke out as seemed inevitable in
deciphering German ciphers that have
been done on this enigma machine now an
awful lot of the material that I am
going to be using today really uses as a
reference book this one by Andrew Hodges
it's called Alan Turing the Enigma this
has been reprinted republished I think
in a slightly new edition because the
imitation game is based on this account
of cheering's life now a back a
long way prior to is used by the German
armed forces it was just a simple
commercial cipher machine and it was a
pretty reasonable system but I suppose
you could say that the number of
possibilities the the degree to which it
scrambled up the message was
considerable but not ultra ultra safe I
think it was a machine that as they say
in the Crypt illogical trade was
designed to discourage casual snooping
rather than to withstand serious
attention from experts in the field and
what I want to do is to go through with
you in this video the components of the
system
then in a later one summarize and say
that's the pearl the problem they were
up against how do you make a machine
that could help you decipher that code
if you didn't know the settings of the
machine that you created it in the first
place
I mentally cross refer you to some
footage on our sister channel
numberphile
James grime has done a couple of videos
on numberphile which actually use a real
live in nygma machine that belongs to
Simon Singh the lucky James gets to use
the real thing and I would strongly
recommend if you're puzzled by all of
this go and watch those two videos one
of them is just a generalized
introduction to the enigma the other one
that explains precisely why the enigma
machines big flaw was that it could
never earn cipher a letter as itself
believe it or not that is a big big
security flaw and just provide a way in
for people who want to crack that
particular code the enigma itself looks
at first sites a bit like an ordinary
typewriter it's got a typewriter board
layout this typewriter keys but you then
notice that if you switch it on and it
is battery powered in the area just
above the keys it's going 26 further
keys you'll have 26 places where a lamp
can light up a letter see my presser t
and it will light up as a G what else is
there inside this machine how does the
key press get through to illuminating a
lamp well in the most amazing and
convoluted way there's a set of rotors
here these rotors have 26 alphabetic
letters engraved around the
circumference sometimes you don't get a
letter you get numbers 0 1 3 2 26 but it
comes down to the same thing in the end
when the lid is closed on top of them
the letter as it were pointing upwards
on the rotor anywhere between eh-2-zed
shows up in three identical looking
windows perhaps the easiest way to think
of it in for those of you viewing who
were relatively young can you remember
back to your family's first ever car
where it had an old
and odometer you know a mileage
indicator on the dashboard which wasn't
all done in electronics it was actually
driven off the engine and you actually
had little wheels moving in front of you
and on the right-hand side would be the
tenths of a mile or tenths of a
kilometer and every time that I got up
to 9 it would nudge the dial to the left
of it to move on one place and so on
the principle is exactly the same on the
Enigma the right-hand rotor moves the
fastest and at a certain stage you will
nudge the next one into moving on a
knotch
the left-hand rotor is the slowest
moving of all and once the lid is closed
on the Enigma all you see is the letter
on the rotor that's uppermost showing
through the windows at the top now
complication upon complication within
each rotor there is if you like on the
two sides an input stud and an output
stud and they are cross wired if you
could break open as is shown here the
rotor mechanism you would see a whole
bunch of 26 wires in there which are
cross wiring an input stud to an output
stud so you might get a cross wide 2j b
cross wire to q-see croft white W
something like that when enigma first
came out there were three sorts of rotor
wheel numbered 1 2 and 3 in Roman
numerals typically in the German
instruction manuals a rotor of type 2
would not be cross wired in the same way
as a rotor of Taiwan and similarly a
rotor of type 3 will be a completely
different cross wiring I think many of
you will know the number of ways you can
arrange three things on a spindle like
that is three factorial which is six six
possible orderings of the rotors on the
spindle so you can begin to see the
multiplication of the number of
combinations about how this thing could
be set up in the first place you've got
different orderings on the spindle
you've got different cross wirings
within different sorts of rotors so the
very basic machine there
that was just about it you fed the
signal through the rightmost rotor
through the middle rotor with a
different cross wiring and mapping
through the left-hand rotor and then
there was what the Germans called a
reverse er sometimes English called a
reflector what he would do was to return
the signal bad fire a different stud on
the left-hand rotor so it would take a
different journey back through the
machine to the way it came in now here
is the secret of why it never mapped a
letter to itself it couldn't because to
make that effect happen you'd have had
in the reflector drum here to say ah
it's coming out of the a Schloss I'm
going to return it back through the a
slot
it wasn't electrically set up to enable
you to do that you effectively had to
decide to cross wire in that reflector
to something different and I think here
if you look carefully a is actually
cross Y just thing like W now in the
early three rotor enigma that reflector
had fixed cross wirings which was the
same on all Enigma machines so your
current goes back through a different
route and then finally lights up a lamp
on the lamp array just ahead of the
keyboard over here so that's the way it
was up until about the mid 30s but then
as the German armed forces were taking
more and more interest in these things
and say always we could beef them up
these could be made into military-grade
security devices they did two things
first thing they said we're not just
going to have three rotors in six
combinations we're going to do the
following we're going to invent two more
rotors called four and five amazingly
here's what you now do we will choose
any three out of those five rotors well
the ways of picking 3 from 5 is 5 times
4 over 1 times 2 5 factorial over 3
factorial ounces 10 but for though each
of those 10 ways you can still jumble
them up in sick
weighs on the spindle 10 times 6 is 60
so classic army airforce enigma use this
pretty well throughout the war
you chose 3 from 5 and the 3 gyros could
be put in the spindle in a certain way
now comes the real killer if that wasn't
bad enough the Armed Forces decided that
on the input to the machine on the
output they would have another cross
wiring board called the plug board now
this one's simple to understand it's
basically got sockets numbered from A to
Z and you're given chunks of wire if the
instructions say cross link a to J
that's what you did
cross link B to are you did that as well
usual operating practice 10 out of 13 of
those plugs would be Crosswhite and
wired up you could wire up in pairs but
you didn't absolutely have to wire up
everything if you left something unwired
or unstick it as they would say in
german then that's fine I mean a letter
Q might have no plug in it going
absolutely nowhere fine so Q maps to Q
is not altered to anything else at all
but like I said typically 10 out of 13
will be wired up so this is getting to
be a pretty complex machine now and you
would think by golly surely this is
enough security for anybody well what's
good enough for the Army in the Air
Force in almost any Armed Forces in the
world is never good enough for the Navy
I think it's that case in the UK
certainly that way in the US and it
certainly was that way in Germany
Admiral Karl dönitz who was the head of
the German it was a very smart guy
some people theorize and maybe they're
right that he strongly suspected as a
war went on that maybe Army and Air
Force enigma was being decrypted
successfully sometimes by the Allies he
was determined to make the the German
Navy
version of ending my far harder so first
thing he did was say alright we'll stick
with three rotors for the moment but it
doesn't choose three from five its
choose three from eight and by the time
you would set out how many ways to pick
three from eight and then multiply by
six for the number of ways you can
arrange the three of chosen on the spin
ball
the answer is 336 and as daunting one of
the things that I think does need a bit
of careful explanation it's not very
well done in the various books about
Bletchley Park and enigma and how it
worked is to explain what these so
called a ring setting as well now the
straightforward internal cross wiring is
simple you just look at the top row and
for every letter you follow vertically
downwards and you say okay in a tight
one rotor a on one side gets mapped to e
on the opposite side B gets mapped to K
C gets mapped to M all the way through
to Z gets mapped to J but to complicate
matters just a little bit further every
one of these rotor rings add a little
blob of paint associated with it showing
which was the proper setting with a at
the top and a against the dot of paint
but it had the ability to be able to
turn the thing in such a way that you
still have a beam against the canonical
blob something else was so you could set
a little notch that held it in position
but in the place that actually was not
the standard position if you put your
button your ring setting button against
the letter B it had the effect of making
a map across to what B would normally
have turned into B would normally have
turned into K B goes to M C goes to F D
goes to L and so on it's just an
offsetting mechanism it's just moving as
it were the bunch of wires inside the
so that is what a ring setting is it's
basically an initial offset that changes
the mapping a versus up Li makes things
even more complicated final bit of
complication now just so that we're
completely mind blown and thinking how
on earth could this ever be decrypted by
anybody that you might think that just
as a car's odometer would go all the way
up to nine on the right-hand side and
the moment it turns over at nine it
would nudge the next one on on the left
some bright spark had the idea that it
might give more security if you made
different wheel types have different
turnover points and a donut is extra
rotors six seven and eight even worse
they turn over twice once it's said and
once a dam in the middle of the alphabet
actually it's not a good idea if you
think about it and I'll tell you why
imagine you know because you've done a
lot of work on this you're pretty sure
that's at the moment the machine has got
a type one rotor at the right and you're
also pretty sure from the Crypt
analytical work you've done that it's
currently on the letter n you then type
in three more of the receive to
ciphertext letters and you certainly see
you've so many fine things going
completely weird this isn't just the
same wheel turning something's happening
it shouldn't have come out looking like
this this sequence oh it's turned over
the middle rotor so if I think it was on
N and it's turned over the middle rotor
on a cue then it follows that that
right-hand rotor must have be of type 1
and I wanted to know that all along
so these turnover points because they
weren't all at said to a which would
have made it all look uniform you know
whenever anything turns over it that's
way it does it has this little signature
that if you're very careful new
cryptanalysis gives the game away how is
it all gathered together if you were
very lucky in the very early days
the war you didn't even have to try and
crypt analyze this incoming ciphertext
traffic either by hand or by machine if
you could do what Bletchley Park called
a pinch you could actually get a secret
agent or an army officer to just
accidentally be able to get hold of the
code tables issued to the German armed
forces kitchens have to do any
cryptanalysis at all either by a hand or
by using this very expensive machinery
that we'll be talking about next time
this electromechanical bomb you didn't
have to use those it's all here but as
James makes very clear in his videos if
you did get that bit of luck it never
lasted long you maybe got a month's
worth and then it ran out or somebody
back at headquarters said I'm not happy
one of our code books seems to be stolen
and disappeared tell you what even
though the six months to go on it we're
throwing it away and we're issuing
another one just to be on the safe side
we've assumed and it's quite right that
the good thing about in enigma from the
Crypt analysis point of view it started
off life as a commercially available
totally open machine so you might think
well the wiring inside those routers
then three of the routers at least one
two and three will be known yes but of
course the moment the luftwaffe and the
arm is starting introducing two more
routers you then got the problem of can
we steal these things or do we have to
work out from first principles and with
rather a lot of advanced group theory in
mathematics and a lot of known
ciphertext and plaintext from all sorts
can we work out what the wiring is in
those routers without actually having
them and the answer is eventually yes
but it's very very nice if somebody
helps you on this front what did you
need to know in order to decrypt a
cipher stream done with enigma that your
listening stations had picked up it was
transmitted in Morse as single letters
sent to Bletchley Park what do you need
to know to make any sense of this number
one which rotor wheels are in use number
two
what is the ordering left-to-right of
those rotor wheels
number three for each of those rotor
wheels where has that stud been
allocated that does the ring setting
against which letter forth thing which
we haven't mentioned very much but which
in the next video will say a lot about
the operator himself usually himself not
herself had to also do what was called a
message setting for this particular
message every separate message had to
have a different message setting it
wouldn't have been safe just to keep
using the ring settings alone without
any alteration to those so that's has to
be worked out as well and finally last
but not least the plugboard cross
connections had to be worked out now
that's a lot of stuff in the very early
days of simple enigmas whether early
three rotors not chosen from anything
else just three we'll find out next time
that the Polish cipher Bureau had a lot
of success by hand and with a very
simple machine in getting things
decrypted but the moment you start
adding more rotors plugboard and all the
complications you rapidly find that you
just don't have enough time in the day
to decrypt all that you'd like to do the
sheer weight of cypher traffic takes
over you have to mechanize
the wires of the circuit are inside the
rotors so when the wires turn the
battery will connect to a different bulb
let's try and see that happen six
options are wrong that means your rotor
position is wrong and what you do is you
go click you check the next rotor
position and you go through all that
again